[Music]
good afternoon everyone
thank you all for coming I know it's the
last session of the day so hopefully
you're not all trying to run out the
door and get beers or whatever at the
end of the day but thank you all very
much again for coming to server list
security made simple my name is Mike
McDonald I'm a product manager on Google
cloud platform working on cloud
functions App Engine and the newly
announced cloud run product so just to
kind of baseline how many people would
say they know what the word security
means but beyond that nothing so I kind
of intro beginner security okay
couple couple folks maybe like
intermediate maybe like you wrote a
crypto algorithm in college once okay
and then let's say like advanced
security people so like you
professionally write crypto algorithms
which you shouldn't do don't do that
don't ever roll your own crypto okay so
good good baseline there we're actually
going to start off just kind of talking
very broad brushstrokes so there's kind
of no assumption of you know anything
about you know crazy security things now
we're gonna try and get on a baseline of
you know hey what are threats what are
some common threats that you might deal
with and then actually say okay what
about in service right server this
allows you to forget about a bunch of
those threats but also kind of
introduces some new ones that we need to
deal with and then lastly running
service on Google cloud again because
you're running on a managed environment
we can eliminate some of those threats
and we give you some tools to deal with
other ones and then lastly we have our
friends from protego who are gonna do a
demo on you know how they can also bring
their product on top of our server the
solutions to further increase your
security cool so we're gonna start off
on a baseline of what is a threat
environment right and so we start off
with a very high-level view of that and
it's kind of the category of who are the
people or systems that may attack you
right and those could be everything from
you know hackers for profit on the
internet foreign governments though most
likely it's you know people inside your
organization who screw things up right
they accidentally ples press RM RF you
know dot star and delete everything
right that is still a threat that you
have to
deal with and then similarly you know in
addition to knowing who your threats are
or you know who the attackers might be
understanding kind of what targets are
available right if you have a database
publicly accessible on the internet
that's an obvious target but there may
be some other less obvious targets right
there have been a lot of interesting you
know hacking attacks where someone had a
password written on a post-it note that
was in the back of the photo right like
that's potentially a target that you
have to deal with and then lastly what
tools might be used right if you
understand who is attacking you the
targets that they're attacking and the
tools that you're that they're using you
have a much better way of understanding
how you can defend against those threats
right because that's what you're trying
to do you're not trying to outrun
everyone you're trying to outrun the
other slow people right you your
security has to be better than everyone
else and that's hopefully why you're
coming to serverless because you get a
bunch of that for free and then you
configure the little bits on top so this
is also one of my favorite comics
hopefully everyone here reads a lot of
xkcd right but there's kind of this
hacker world of you know oh god the
laptop is encrypted we need to you know
write a new algorithm do it but the
reality is you know it's a five dollar
wrench that gets the password on the
laptop right and so that's kind of this
idea of threat models you want to
optimize for the what's gonna happen
commonly and defend against that rather
than those kind of you know scenarios
that maybe you dream of but are low low
probability so this talk is actually
kind of modeled off of a couple of kind
of top ten threats that we see in server
lists so the OWASP server list top ten
and the cloud security group serverless
security top twelve and those are kind
of the obviously top threats that they
see there's a lot of overlap between
these and we're gonna go through a
number of them so things like what
malicious code is and where you might
get it and you know potential for remote
code execution denials of service
storing your credentials in securely and
then everything down to even this idea
of poor developer experience right if
your developers have a manual tool chain
they're copying things around there's a
much higher chance that something's
gonna go wrong
which is a threat to your environment so
we're going to start off with this idea
of a zero-day so how many people have
heard of zero days everyone in the room
exactly so why does it matter right why
is a zero day so bad
typically you have this thing called the
window of vulnerability so a
vulnerability is disclosed so like
Specter or meltdown you know right we
get an email that's like oh my god this
terrible thing happened there's a patch
out you know you can go and fix using
this patch and that's where this kind of
danger zone begins right everyone knows
that this is a vulnerability and it can
be exploited but ideally you know you
can patch things quickly enough that
that danger zone is relatively small
that window of vulnerability is
relatively small the problem with zero
days and really you know kind of any
unknown vulnerability is that that
danger zone is now much much larger
right there is an x-point active
somewhere in the wild maybe it's a
remote code execution in your function
or you know some insecure credential
that you don't know about and until you
discover it you know kind of this T
equals zero all the way up to the
present where it's active that's a very
very dangerous place and why this is
important is those things could occur
anywhere in your stack right so if
you're building on top of you know some
VM like you know I have a server like a
Raspberry Pi at home running things on
the Internet I'm responsible for you
know hardware and network on that I have
to patch the operating system you know
when something like specter happens I am
responsible for that I'm running a node
server on top of that I'm responsible
for updating node whenever it gets there
security patches and then I'm also
responsible for the dependencies that
I'm pulling in in my app in addition to
my app code right and that's a lot for
me to think about when my raspberry pi
server is you know controlling my light
bulb right but if you know and it's
relatively low you know risk if my light
bulb gets hacked but it's a lot of stuff
that I have to worry about and I would I
would like it obviously if my light
didn't turn on at random times and so
the whole goal of server list is to
reduce what you're thinking about right
shove all of those you know potential
vulnerabilities you know the zero days
they're gonna wipe out your application
because you're not worried about
updating the operating system you're not
worried about updating the hardware
you're not even worried about updating
the language runtime in many cases
you're just focusing on what matters to
you and your business which is the
application code that you write and the
dependencies that you're pulling in so
we do a couple things for you in this
world right if you're using cloud
functions app engine or cloud run we are
automatically doing a bunch of those
upgrades so in the cloud functions case
things like your function framework so
the code that actually wraps that that
little function that you write the
language runtime and operating system
same on App Engine language runtime and
operating system and then on cloud run
so cloud run is our newest serverless
containers product where you can
actually provide an arbitrary container
image which could have you know some
crazy operating system you could be
pulling in native dependencies we don't
know so we can't do kind of the same you
know operating system level things you
know potentially yet there is a world
where we're looking at hey we'll give
you a you know Google a boon to base
image that we are automatically
upgrading or a Google Python based image
that we're automatically updating so
stay tuned for more of that of how we
kind of make that world a little better
and then there's another question and it
was actually asked downstairs in our
server list panel earlier today of right
we are running a bunch of containers
under the hood for all of those products
and we're running in them in a
multi-tenant environment that's how we
can scale to you know ten thousand
containers in five seconds and we're
doing that because we run on this
massive multi-tenant infrastructure and
there's a really cool product called G
visor so G visor is an open source
kernel you can go to G visor dot dev and
it basically intercepts all of the Syst
calls from the the kind of developer
untrusted container and then would remap
them or disallow them so that you can't
have you know people going and you know
messing with other containers we also
have a thing called G contain our G
container that does kind of the same
idea but for you know memory and CPU so
you can't have you know kind of noisy
neighbors taking up other other you know
resources on that multi-tenant
environment okay
so that's kind of you know base what
Google does for you let's talk about
another one so malicious code and remote
code execution so it turns out there are
lots and lots of ways to get bad code
right the internet is a very scary place
number one just like don't trust
anything that pulls code from paste bin
right like there have been a number of
vulnerabilities there was a great one
last year in ES lint where you know
someone checked in code that just pulled
from an arbitrary paste bin URL and then
eval bat code and wrote it to another
place bin URL like those are kind of
obvious ones but there are you know some
other
you know having other low-quality
dependencies that may not be as obvious
such as you know maybe there are
performance bugs like they do crazy
regular expression parsing that end up
causing causing performance issues or
another really common one is you have
multiple environments and so you have
you know a development environment where
your developers can do whatever they
want and then you have a production
environment that's more locked down and
maybe if you're sharing those
environments dependencies will make
their way over from development through
testing and into production and maybe
they don't have the performance or the
security you know requirements that you
have so how do you know about any of
those vulnerabilities by the way right
if you're using an open-source package
how would you have any idea if it was
vulnerable so there are a bunch of
three-letter acronyms that I'm going to
throw out and by the way feel free yes
take photos so that you don't have to
remember them all so see bees I'm sure a
lot of people have heard of these so it
is kind of a a way of tracking these
common vulnerabilities and exposures and
they do so by assigning every CVE a
number and so CNAs provide numbering for
those so you'd see you know CVE one two
three four five is X and so open source
project so note is a great example of
this they have a they node CVE numbering
authority so every single node issue
gets a number goes into their tracking
system and then you can look it up using
these so these are kind of the open
source databases for you know taking a
look at hey what vulnerabilities may be
out there there are also you know a
bunch of other tools if you're you're
more in this space that have kind of you
know scraped this and provided it in a
in a better world
so things like green keeper or sneak are
great ways of just kind of hey I want to
actually kind of make sense of this and
even potentially check my dependencies
locally and then I think we'll have a
demo later of doing this as well cool so
denials of service another attack that I
think a lot of people have heard of so
kind of a classic denial of service that
everyone thinks about is you know you
have some fixed number of resources you
have external traffic coming in and now
maybe you have malicious traffic and so
that traffic starts coming in and it
overwhelms the resources and your
machines
are backing up and failing so serverless
actually introduces another several like
relatively interesting denial of service
attacks you can have the traditional
resource exhaustion where you know hey
your function or your app only has two
gigs of ram and you'll run out of RAM or
you know you only have so much network
throughput um but you know because we're
kind of focusing more on code you can
have some some other really interesting
ones of you know code errors that maybe
it was a correct request but due to you
know some regular expression bug now you
end up with resource exhaustion and then
my personal favorite which is very kind
of new for server lists right serverless
infrastructure scales infinitely right
hopefully you saw that demo of you know
0 to 10,000 instances I've profiled it
and that's you know a million requests a
second the thing that will run out first
is your credit card right that you're
gonna you're gonna hit that and you
don't want a 10,000 dollar bill or a
hundred thousand dollar bill and things
will start breaking right and so that's
kind of this financial denial of service
that server list is is so great it's so
great on one side and results in this
interesting problem on the other so a
really common one here again with
functions we will start scaling up and
maybe there's this kind of impedance
mismatch right so for those of you who
have used you know sequel databases you
can run out of file descriptors right
you have so many machines on the front
end trying to connect to this and you'll
exhaust your resources so we provide a
really nice tool that allows you to max
the set a maximum number of those
functions that are running right so
functions are single concurrency they're
handling one request so you can actually
say I want four instances because I know
that I have a back-end resource that can
only handle four concurrent connections
or whatever the number is and we can set
that upper bound and what will happen
now is we will start getting extra
external traffic we will start spinning
up resources and then above that we will
start kind of loadshedding that and
applying back pressure and so we'll
start queuing up all those requests
we're not gonna drop them but we will
just start processing them so you only
kind of get four at a time so it's a
nice way of again when you have this
impedance mismatch of serverless can
scale infinitely but maybe the back-end
resources that you're using can't you
can use max instances to try and solve
that
it's worth noting that apps and
containers running on cloud run are
multi concurrent by default so I
mentioned functions are single
concurrency so they're doing one request
per instance apps will actually do
multiple requests per instance so if
you're running App Engine or cloud run
we will actually start sending those
requests back to your application so for
cloud run for instance we say you get a
concurrency limit of 80 by default so
you know every instance you know
assuming it doesn't run out of you know
memory or CPU you know it's it's kind of
bound to 80 concurrent requests and
obviously you can put that higher or
lower depending on what you need but
just something to kind of you know know
if you really want you could set you
know your cloud run app to single
concurrency and go back to that model
but we give you that flexibility okay
insecure credential storage right don't
store passwords in plain text I feel
like I don't need to say that but it
still happens especially when people
write you know really kind of small
things there are a lot of places where
you're going to encounter credentials
and you may need to store them so
storing database username and password
right I see it all the time maybe you're
doing Oh auth credentials so you're
signing a user in and you're storing
access tokens you're doing some kind of
ripped oh maybe you have symmetric keys
or you're storing asymmetric keys or
similarly maybe you have like
publication credentials and so
publishing your code to github or
deploying it we'll talk about the most
common one that I see so storing secrets
in code right you end up with we're
connecting in our function to a my
sequel database and you know someone
says hey here the username and password
right and your function code can leak
maybe you accidentally make your github
repo public and everything is bad right
someone can just connect to this
database and take your data so maybe you
want to do something like storing
secrets and environment variables that
kind of solves one of the problems of
hey let's just set the database user to
root and store it there and your code
looks a lot better right it just says
hey you know process and DB user DB
password now if this gets public on the
internet it's fine because you're
binding those credentials in when you
actually deploy in the environment
variable but there are actually a bunch
of other potential issues in that world
we'll actually I think see an attack on
that at the end in a demo and so you may
want to consider things like cloud kms
so cloud kms will let
you do encryption of say a file in GCS
and so you can store all of your secrets
in that file and then pull them out or
similarly if you want to use a tool like
hash e-court vault
maybe you're already running an instance
of that within your own company we also
have a link there if you want to run
vault on TCP and those are kind of you
know more secure ways of storing secrets
and there's a really great blog post by
one of our developer advocates Seth on
how to do those so I think he writes a
bunch of go functions and a bunch of
Python functions that show how to do a
number of different kind of secrets in
serverless type of scenarios cool so
those are all kind of you know some of
them are unique to service but most of
them are kind of just general
application security things execution
flow manipulation I think is much more
unique to service and here's why so we
can imagine that I'm building you know a
function that deploys or that writes
some content to a cloud sequel instance
but the reality is right these are micro
services so I'm gonna actually break
them apart into the smallest unit of
whatever they were doing you know so
that's one line of code so maybe I want
to save some content maybe I have a
markdown file and I'm writing it to HTR
and transforming it to HTML and then
saving the HTML into a database so I'll
have one function that's hey you know I
want to process some content and that
does markdown to HTML and then one thing
that actually saves the HTML so you can
imagine you know the happy path here was
just straight through my one function
calls my second function my second
function calls the database but in this
case right these functions are you know
public on the internet people can just
kind of call around them and you may get
a malicious call that's like hey I just
want to save you know some arbitrary
data that's maybe not HTML or maybe not
markdown or anything it kind of doesn't
respect the flow of the application
that's a problem so we've introduced in
actually in cloud run you can already go
and use it today and in in cloud
functions it's an alpha we're still
working on rolling that out it's kind of
hard to add to a generally available
product but what it does is it allows
you to specify cloud iam policies on
your functions and your services and so
that would allow you to authenticate
developers or end-users or you know the
other
services be they you know clawed
functions or cloud run services or you
know on-prem things you're
authenticating with the service account
and the other big change here is that
services will become private by default
so in cloud run when you deploy your
cloud run instance it's already private
and you have to make it public manually
by adding you know a policy down there
so that - - allow authenticated sets all
users can invoke this this service
similarly with functions so what does it
look like we can have our first function
that process content function say I want
to allow anyone to invoke me so we're
gonna say all users get you know the
cloud functions invoker role and on our
second function we're actually gonna say
ok you know only this first function can
invoke me so that provides you know a
little bit of security where someone
can't come around right so we've now
secured that channel between our two
functions so when someone tries to come
in and save data directly I am is like
nope we don't allow that you can't do it
but for your developers they can just
say hey I want to curl this using an
identity token that I'm pulling from G
cloud or that I've generated via some
other tool and they can go and actually
test that out if they want and what
about other cloud services right so
maybe it's not a human user that it's
calling your process content functions
maybe you have a scheduled job or you
have task queues or you have data coming
from pub/sub right so each of those
products so cloud scheduler tasks and
pub/sub can get a service count with a
role so that could be you know cloud
function invoker or similarly and they
can then make authenticated requests out
to you know GC f or cloud run or other
services on the internet and it's both
you know secure it in transit via SSL
but then also it gives that identity
token that can be validated by the IAM
stuff that we just talked about so takes
that token along they validate it
awesome and as I mentioned also
available in pub sub you can do
authenticated push subscriptions out of
pub sub so it's really really nice for
kind of creating this very secure
environment ok and then I actually saw a
question on the dory so hopefully
whoever asked this is here there's a
question about network restrictions so
the only app engine of those three
products offers firewalls
so actually cloud functions and cloud
run don't yet offer them they are not
yet integrated with cloud armor but that
is something that we're looking into in
at Google App Engine you can say hey I
do want to create a firewall and that
would be you know if you know that there
is some known malicious actor you can
blacklist that IP or maybe you are
operating within an environment where
you need to whitelist certain ones
otherwise strongly recommend identity
based security a lot of large companies
that I've talked to you do kind of this
strong outer wall and then no security
inside and that's obviously not good
because if someone does penetrate that
that outer wall they can do whatever
they want and identity based security
kind of going back to to those
granularity to it to a granular or
anything sort of you know it makes the
barrier feel a little more permeable but
generally every service has their own
little wall around it which kind of
makes that more secure it's all
trade-offs in engineering okay so
continuing on the you know ways of
authenticating your application we see a
lot of times that people end up with
over privileged identities in those
functions so by default every function
shares the same identity and that
identity has the editor role so we can
actually go and spin up VMs and do a
bunch of things and that's basically
because we said hey we know that people
want to you know build functions to demo
things really quickly they should be
able to do that without having to learn
all the complexities of I am but we then
said okay well obviously if you're
deploying these things in production you
need this concept of least privilege
where your function can only access the
one thing that it needs and so that is
where this concept of per function
identity comes in and it says okay we
know that this function needs exactly
this role we don't want it shared with
anyone and that's how we actually talked
a little bit earlier about how you know
our save or a process content function
can talk to our save data function and
only those so we can walk through an
example of that I can create a service
account called process content and I can
say ok on cloud functions I'm going to
grant on that save data function I'm
going to say ok service account process
content at whatever gets the cloud
functions invoker role and then I can
deploy my function use
that service account and so what I've
done is I've said okay on function a you
know you get this specific role I'm
going to deploy you with that and on
function B that function can invoke it
and then we can do the same thing
actually for our second function so our
second function is talking to a cloud
sequel instance so we can say okay we'll
give you the save data function or we'll
give you a service account called save
data and we'll do the same thing right
we'll say hey on the project give you
the cloud sequel client role so you can
actually create a connection to cloud
sequel and then we will deploy our
function using that so now with per
function identity function a can talk to
function B and function B can talk to
our database and really the important
thing here is function B can't go and
talk to any other thing right it can't
go out and talk to GCS or any of the
other you know cloud services because it
doesn't have that access and what about
things with in-network restrictions
right so maybe you're not running you
know called sequel instance maybe you're
running you know some other database
that doesn't you know integrate well
with cloud I am but it's within a VP C
so you're running that on cloud and we
obviously you know can't just make an
HTTP request to your VP see you can use
a VP see connector so these are now in
beta and they allow you to talk to
instances obviously within a VP C so GCE
your gke things like cloud memory store
that are also running you know within a
VP C and then even on Prem you can go
through compute running in that vb c on
to on Prem so again you can figure out
deploy time you say G cloud functions
deploy with a vp c connector and that
will let you kind of go through that
connector to that compute okay I'll let
photos photos continue and then can we
switch over to the demo machine please
okay
wants me to relaunch Chrome yes so what
we're looking at is kind of the well
you're looking at all of my functions I
have a lot of them and we have a really
really you know simple view of the app
that we just created so we have function
a and function B
and what function a does is function a
literally just proxies to function B we
can actually look at the source over
here and we can say hey it's going to
fetch a token and then call our other
function with that token and then
function B literally just returns 200
okay there's it's not even worth looking
at it's a really really small function
but as you just saw currently anyone on
the Internet can talk to either of those
functions right but we really want it
such that function a or function B can
only be accessed by function a so over
in the service accounts page I created
function a and a thing called no role
where I just say hey you know this is a
service account that I want to give no
permissions to and what we can do to
secure our app is we can edit function a
so currently it has the default compute
service count so we could say hey we
want to give you function a service
account we will redeploy you and then we
can on function B open up that
permissions tab and you'll notice
so the invoker permission which allows
anyone to you to access it it has all
users currently it's a public function
so we'll delete that and just to prove
to you that's deleted so come on takes a
second to propagate Oh should B be live
demos are always fun well just create a
new one function B okay I think I have
given it one second to do function B we
will add to function B oh the service
count from function a and then I will
debug it a little more so we can just
paste that in and say yep the function a
service count we will give you the cloud
functions invoke a role and save that
and as you can see there are a lot of
who else has oh they're probably I'm
assuming that that role has been given
another or that user has been given
another
let's just quickly try it again okay oh
I think I well I must have flipped
something let's take a look over here
again so over here I have given function
a all users well and then function B I
will just actually redeploy it with it's
no roll service account instead of the
App Engine default one and see what it
does we'll just give that a second - two
- but the end result should be not this
where we should get okay through there
and we should there so this is it's been
redeployed and that is not public on the
Internet and then this one that is okay
so there we go
took a little while but we're there and
so what we've done again
function a is running with its
particular service account we can go and
check that out so it even says hey it's
running under the function a service
count function B will be running under
that no roll service count and I'll just
pull them out and we'll refresh them
manually to prove there we go okay back
to the slides please okay so there are a
couple of other issues that we may face
along the way so we talked about this
concept of least privilege within GCP of
your function only being able to talk to
you know cloud sequel instance and not a
GCS instance for instance so there are a
couple of other ways that data may be
exfiltrated from your app for instance
you know that process content function
instead of sending you know making that
HTTP request to save data maybe it's
gonna say oh you know it's send it to
evil calm and steal all of that data
right and that could be caused by you
know something like a remote code
execution or maybe you have you know
that the name of that URL is in a
variable and someone you know somehow
got in there and changed it and another
similar one is right maybe the path is
the same we
you know you're still storing data
correctly but now someone has you know
dump your environment and is saving that
to the database and now your data is
stored somewhere where it shouldn't and
maybe you know you have another thing
that says you know you have another
function that's read content and now
they can read the content of your
database username and password right
there are a number of very interesting
threats along that model and a similar
one caught that actually could cause
those is things like query injection
right so hopefully everyone has heard of
you know sequel injection attacks
another xkcd comic about little bobby
tables i don't name your kid a sequel a
valid sequel statement because things
will not end well
highly recommend just reading all of
xkcd by the way it's great great stuff
and so right you know maybe we have our
save data function and it does something
like this right it's like hey you know
I'm gonna create this query string and
just save my data directly into the
database and pull it in you know
directly from the body well that's great
until you know you name the user Mike
drop tables posts right and then we're
inserting that directly into our
database right wouldn't it be great if
you know a we could write a bunch of
code to manually escape that you know we
could even do the like galaxy brain
thing of a lot of a lot of sequel
libraries will actually provide a really
nice way of doing those queries for you
that automatically escape them but there
are actually a number of third party
providers some of whom we have here in
the room today who can make this a
little easier right so folks like
intrinsic protego and pure SEK offer a
number of categories of Defense's for
your server list applications and so
some of them occur at Build time so
preventing you know the the shipping
your functions with editor role because
they can say hey based on data we've
seen you know you should only need these
you know these three privileges and then
they can also do things like you know
check all of those tve databases to make
sure that your dependencies aren't
vulnerable and then they also provide a
category of runtime defenses right so
you know doing the kind of Web
Application Firewall type things to
prevent sequel injection or restricting
read from the file system so someone
can't just dump your entire process or
read all the local files or doing things
like controlling outbound networking
right so don't send data
- evil calm so I'll highlight one of the
tools and then we can have protego come
up on stage and demonstrate theirs so
one of them is called function shield so
by pure sec and it does a couple of
things so you can just say disable
outbound networking or disable read and
write from slash temp and you can do a
couple of things you can say hey I want
to actively block all of these or you
can say like hey I only want to alert on
them so you know it shows up in
stackdriver logging it says hey it looks
like this request was attempted you know
we would have failed that if you were
kind of in strict mode otherwise you
know we're just letting you know so this
is kind of more about the letting you
know and then potentially locking things
down so for instance I run my functions
most of them don't need to create child
processes and so I say yep you know
alert me on outbound HTTP but disallow
read and write from temp disallow you
know child processes don't allow anyone
to read the source code that kind of
thing and then how well do you wanna
come up he can give a demo on protego
and what kind of they provide in this
space I'll hand you that though I don't
know if you need any but he did I was
sure I'd fill in the steps that was my
big vision cool Thanks so thanks Mike
so before I hit play right I'll figure
that out before I play just a quick word
about what we do so I think Mike set it
up in terms of what we look at in terms
of security both at build time and at
run time for security are one of our
particular focuses is on using automated
tools to understand what the code does
in order to automate all the
configuration of the things that might
just talked about so try to make it so
that you don't have to sit there and
configure what you think your function
should do or shouldn't do but rather
developers write code and security
people can be you know assured that the
code can do the things that can do and
then the security policy is going to
prevent the things that it can't do
that's a big focus for us so whether
it's I am roles run time policy
permissions you know defense etc all
that is automated in a way that's driven
by code so let's see a quick demo so
this is you know we announced
availability of a product for AWS those
guys back in September we've been hard
working at getting the things that we do
to work well on JCP and take advantage
of some of the cool things that are in
this platform and I think we expect
don't don't don't record me but by the
end of the quarter it's about two months
to be able to be list let's say public
beta if not availability but I wanted to
give you a quick glimpse of what the
product does and how it works so I'm
gonna hit play I may hit pause a little
bit just if I see it's running too best
I did two things okay first of all I was
going to apologize for recording my demo
but now I feel better cuz live demos are
always bad and it was are hard and I I I
feel like you okay so here's that here's
the quick setup wait if I hit space with
a pause yes cool here's the quick setup
we've got a single function app running
in Google Cloud it is a slack chat bot
so we're gonna interact with it through
slack we're gonna send message message
just do it through slack we're gonna get
meta messages back well do it look just
a quick tour of what's in the app and
what's there and what we're doing and
then we'll just show you how the app
works and then we'll start attacking it
with different attacks and kind of see
how the platform reacts to it so you can
see we've got a function you could see
all the runtime information etcetera you
can see we've got a bucket right can I
can't even see what's going on here yeah
there's a bucket in there clouds
sequences in a bucket it's good that you
can see okay now you can see our
platformer what we see so this is the
particular dashboard you can see kind of
the view of the application
you know what resources krigger is what
we know about it will dig into sin you
know with this particular function you
can see there are two functions we're
gonna go into one of them and show you
kind of the posture of that function so
what is everything that we know about
the function how is it triggered what
can it do what's its runtime all that
information and particularly we're gonna
focus on what are what's it what's it
allowed to do versus what we think it's
supposed to be allowed to do because
we've analyzed understood the code and
so we know which permissions it needs in
which it doesn't need we also know what
things it needs to be able to do at
runtime what processes it needs to be
able to launch we know what network
connections it needs to make and so
those things have been whitelist at
anything else we can that we can then
block and I'll see you head in a second
if we take a look at the task view here
this is our part of our product which is
kind of more than the run the build time
tool but you can see it here in the
product it's telling us hey we've got a
permissive role look at all these
permissions that came by choosing a you
know managed role and actually these are
the only permissions this function needs
to run and if you want to aim for lease
privileges an automated path where you
can build service accounts for each
function that
just the permissions that they need
rather than all the permissions that
come with wild carding or choosing sort
of unmanned your manuals etc we also see
a vulnerable dependency so you know my
talk about that earlier we're detecting
the CVE
for that dependency and giving
information about it so let's interact a
little bit with this chat bot we're
gonna just send some messages to it and
see how it reacts so you can see that
when we write this is about as
sophisticated as it is we type a message
and it type something around them and
hopefully sometimes funny back it also
stores a history of our messages we can
upload files to it so we just wanted to
make sure we had to set up and we can do
all these different injection attacks on
it alright so here well upload a file
and it'll store it etc and you can see
that we put the file in there we'll pop
over to the storage bucket and see that
that file got uploaded to that storage
bucket right let's take a look here we
go so there's our file we just uploaded
so now if we go back and we start seeing
well what what malicious seems to be can
can we do let's try doing a little bit
of sequel injection on this right so
we're seeing that when we ask for latest
messages we're getting back a list of
ladies messages from the database that
makes us think there's some sequel
inside the database we're going to send
a message which has got some sequel
injection in it so remember the
functions would take these messages and
insert them into the database using an
insert query but now that we shoved it a
little select text there as well we're
going to magically get some data stuff
into the database that we shouldn't have
in there and now we can pull it back out
so that was kind of what Mike described
before where we leverage the ability to
do some injection to put something into
the database that we shouldn't have been
there and then we pulled it out now
we'll do another injection attack we're
just in code injection here this code
injection is going to essentially just
do curl inside the function so we're
taking advantage of that nodes
serialized bug that you saw earlier in
the post review where you saw we're
using a vulnerable library let's take
advantage of that and you can see how
when we execute that send that message
to this black chat bot it's generating a
chrome request back to our server so we
now know hey this thing is vulnerable to
code injection cool let's see what other
data we can extract out of it or let's
see what we can do in this case let's
delete the file that we created earlier
which is something we shouldn't be able
to do and what I want to point out about
that is if you saw earlier this function
shouldn't be able to delete things it
doesn't need that permission but we gave
it that permission and now the attacker
can exploit that permission to take
advantage that and delete
he shouldn't be able to delete so had we
configure the iam permissions correctly
for that function we wouldn't be able to
do that now here you can see what
protego sees when these things happen so
in line this stuff is being in this case
we're in alert mode I didn't mention
that we're in alert mode so we're not
blocking anything yet but you can see
all the types of events the particulars
picking up
I see command injection patterns I see
behaviors I didn't expect all these
things are being detected and could be
blocked and you get all that information
and then we can go and switch that into
block mode so we switch our defense mode
in the block mode we can then try the
same attack again and what we see is
that attack wouldn't happen at all so
let's go back to slack and we'll just
try that same injection attack again and
hopefully nothing will happen on the
bottom I say hopefully it's a video
right you guys know it ends there you go
so nothing happens in the bottom so we
try that same injection attack same
mechanism that we taught me that I
showed you before detecting it but now
we're blocking it in line and just to
give a little illustration of that we
can pop into the logs for that function
and we can see what party goes logging
into the logs of that function in real
time as it happens in here you can see
if you look really carefully what the
event was what the you know what the
pattern was or event was that we were
walking and in this case you can see the
type of reaction was blocked as opposed
to it would have been there before which
is alert so we're actually detecting and
blocking in real time as well as
reporting it so that's us well thank you
very much thank you so the last thing
that I want to talk about was a poor
developer experience right so one of the
goals of serverless
is to kind of abstract away a lot of the
toil and give developers a really really
fast way of developing but there are
still kind of developer experience speed
blocks or road blocks along the way so a
number of issues that we see
particularly people using shared
environments right that's a really
common way to pollute your database or
leak credentials or similar things
because you're sharing that information
that really shouldn't be shared across
environments so using project boundaries
to enforce those that that isolation is
kind of a good developer experience
practice and using tools like deployment
manager or terraform to then deploy your
functions right it's really easy to just
do g-cloud functions deploy but
especially for you know your production
and and similar environments you want to
actually have a bunch of that automated
which is going over to our second side
right if you have you know a slow tool
chain or your manual ESC piing files
from one place to another you're going
to end up with security issues just
because people make mistakes right so
setting up CI CD tools so spinnaker or
cloud build to you know hey I actually
have a couple apps that are running in
you know in the cloud source editor so I
added all of my code there I then commit
it to a git repo it's picked up
automatically by cloud build built
entirely
deployed the containers does a traffic
split and everything is kind of safe and
I don't have to worry about it right so
I'm not manually doing those things and
I'm not going to screw it up because I
did it once and I tested it so we
actually already demoed so I'm gonna
just leave that slide there but we have
a couple minutes left if folks have
questions please walk up to a microphone
I don't think we can deliver them
unfortunately but I'm happy to answer
questions otherwise thank you all very
much for coming I really enjoyed it
hopefully you learned a lot
[Applause]
[Music]